[Music]
Prince George caught sticking out his
tongue amid his great-grandmother Queen
Elizabeth's funeral I think the queen
had a really special bond with all of
her grandchildren but particularly with
Prince George and I think that is
because he is an heir to the throne
after the first part of the service at
Westminster Abbey the nine-year-old rode
in a car with his mom Kate little sis
princess Charlotte and step-grandmother
queen consort Camilla
and at some point during the ride a faux
talk snapped the Young Prince with his
tongue out which reminds us of something
all too familiar
foreign
yeah remember when his little bro Prince
Louis stole the show at the Queen's
Platinum Jubilee in June the
four-year-old had the best
Expressions as he wildly waved to the
crowd and chatted to his
great-grandmother the queen
but Louie's cheeky moment might be a
different story than George's tongue
sticking out because there's a good
chance this was just a stroke of luck
from the photographer who might have
caught the young Royal mid lip lick
after all it would be surprising if
George was doing something disrespectful
on the somber day seen as he had a close
bond with his great grand while the
queen at this time with Prince George
she wanted to make sure that she was
there to be a great grandmother of
course but she wanted to be there to
give him those early lessons in
preparing him for kingship which of
course he will learn from his
grandfather King Charles from his father
that there are lessons that only the
queen could have handed down and she was
very lucky that she was able to have
nine years with George to be able to do
that
and aside from his maybe moment of
goofiness George and Charlotte were on
their best behavior during the late
Monarch's funeral which they reportedly
asked to be part of he's nine princess
Charlotte is now seven I'm told that
there was a conversation with his mom
and his dad about were they up to it you
know they put it out they asked the
children how do you feel about it they
wanted to participate in the decision we
just learned about the decision actually
this morning that they were going to
participate and I think it's just
setting a scene I thought of something
interesting because I've done a couple
of specials on the queen she never
expected to be Queen she became second
in line for the throne when she was just
10. she never thought she would actually
be Queen she thought her father would
serve out
Prince George is nine and he now is
second in line for the throne I think
that's an interesting thing to say never
say never right
[Music]